et en direct dans ce gîte et clément
janot a co fondateur de block j partner
bonjour merci d'être avec nous pourquoi
à sortir cette monnaie maintenant en
pleine crise sanitaire
alors c'est intéressant pour la chine
d'abord parce que en amont de cette
crise la chine avait anticipé la sortie
d'un possible libre à cette monnaie
numérique que facebook devait lancer et
qui a pris du retard et en fait déjà en
décembre la chine était censé lancer ses
premières expérimentations ce avait pris
un peu de retard mais finalement la
chine souhaite profiter de cette crise
du coronavirus pour tester une
digitalisation tout comme d'autres
services se digitalise avec le
confinement est d'abord à le tester pour
le versement de prestations auprès de
fonctionnaires dans certaines dans
certaines localités en chine donc
d'abord ça va être très expérimentale au
niveau local et le but c'est d'élargir
petit à petit avec l'objectif sans doute
soit en fin d'année soit l'année
prochaine d'une mise en production
beaucoup plus large pour que ce soit fin
prêt notamment pour 2022 puisqu'il ya
des échéances sportives qui arriva en
chine est ce que cette monnaie numérique
pourrait remplacer l'utilisation
traditionnelle de b
et d'espèces alors c'est possible à
terme puisque l'idée de cette monnaie
numérique c'est bien à terme de pouvoir
remplacer m
0n 0c les billets sceller les pièces
alors il faut avoir raison garder au
départ ça va être très progressif mais
ça s'inscrit bien dans le mouvement de
digitalisation de un certain nombre de
services en chine et dans le mouvement
de d'utilisation de plus en plus encore
une fois numérique du visage de services
financiers elle perd des citoyens on
sait que la chine est pionnière en la
matière avec des géants en privé comme
we chat notamment et là en fait ça
serait l'idée de capitaliser sur cette
cce d'âge qui sont déjà assez glauque et
de widgets et dali bay mais pour aller
au delà et pour toucher notamment les
250 millions de chinois qui possède pas
de compte bancaire puisque avec soan
virtuel ça sera possible de
s'enregistrer uniquement avec un numéro
de téléphone est pour pour débloquer des
plafonds plus élevé il faudrait pièce
d'identité un compte bancaire mais voilà
ils veulent permettre un accès facilité
et à poulets chinois he à terme pour
effectivement possiblement possiblement
remplacer les pièces et les billets ce
qui est déjà assez à c'est le cas vous
savez quand on veut en chine
c'est très c'est très frappant y compris
dans des campagnes assez reculé tout le
monde utilise le chat les habits sdf qui
ont des cuirs cote dans la rue pour
qu'on leur verse de l'argent via wi chat
c'est assez fascinant parfois inquiétant
pour des raisons de surveillance mais en
tout cas ils sont bien plus en avance
que nous en la matière on sait que là
c'est une étude un test locale mais au
niveau national quels seraient les
avantages d'une telle monnaie alors il
ya deux trois grands objectifs pour la
chine le premier c'est très
opérationnelle s'est donné des gains
d'efficience par rapport à la monnaie
papier on imagine assez facilement que
le digital peut aider il ya un objectif
de contrôler aussi pour lutter plus
efficacement contre la fraude contre le
blanchiment d'argent
et puis il ya accès de plus stratégique
qui a trait à la souveraineté monétaire
d'abord pour d'un point de vue défensif
au cas où libre à se seraient
développées où se développerait demain
pour éviter de se retrouver coincé si
libre à demain devient la monnaie
numérique de référence
ça peut être dangereux et donc la chine
cherche à présenter cette question de la
monnaie numérique
en tout cas sur le territoire chinois
pour commencer et puis d'un point de
plus offensif on peut imaginer qu'il ya
eu une visée d'international et
d'internationalisation du yuan notamment
par le biais des routes de la soie qui
pourrait être une des voies justement
pour faire développer ce cette monnaie
virtuelle au delà du territoire
et ça c'est intéressant stratégiquement
notamment pour offrir une alternative au
système swift qui est le système des
occidentales pour les échanges
internationaux
merci clément janot d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
le cofondateur de block chaining
partenaires